three surprising things that I can shell
without one would be sardines in cans so
wild planet sardines in olive oil which
were referred to me by Dominick
D'Agostino that would definitely be one
and I will travel with cases of these
sometimes internationally because they
make a very convenient breakfast I just
pop it open and I will have a plastic or
titanium I have both spork so it is a it
has a spoon on one end and then a fork
on the other and the fork has one
serrated edge you can use as a knife and
I will just always have one of those in
my bag so I guess that's also something
I would travel with but I'll consider
that one piece we have the sardines
which is pretty lights like 250 calories
per can something along those lines and
it's this the perfect ketogenic or
simple breakfast so I'll travel with
sardines and Dominic D'Agostino is just
an incredible researcher and published
scientist who not only develops
exogenously nning synthetic ketones for
people like Navy SEALs and the general
public but can also deadlift 500 pounds
for about 10 repetitions after a six day
fast so I like following his advice so
we have the sardines number two I would
say the I'll count this as as one item
rumble roller which is a foam roller
that has these crazy knobs on it so
incredibly intense it's the only foam
roller has really done anything for me
in the immediate or short term and I
will travel with one of these and check
a bag if need be to carry that which was
introduced to me by Amelia Boone the
world to a successful obstacle course
racer three-time world's toughest Mudder
champion Rumble roller and then the
niyog acupressure mat which looks like a
bed of nails and it rolls up that was
introduced to me by Andrzej bondarenko
of Cirque de Soleil and that is for
mitigating any type of back pain you can
also use it there's a headrest with all
these spikes on it I can flip that over
for instance and put it between my body
and my
and elbow and lay on my elbow and it has
similar pan relieving effects so those
are my body maintenance tools if I just
throw in another one would be the rad
roller for my feet and then third
something strange or unusual I'm going
to say morning journal so morning pages
journal this is a big notebook and it's
based on the work of I believe it's
Julia Cameron who wrote the artists way
and any notebook would really work for
this but I find it convenient since I
bought it to simply use the morning
pages journal and that is for journaling
in the mornings not for anything
intended to be published but to take the
monkey mind and irrational fears
thoughts worries unfocused distractions
in my head and put them on paper so that
I can get on with my day and do things
hopefully productively and with less
anxiety and so on and those are the
items that come to mind if you enjoyed
that video let's talk about a list our
own swardson anger jamie foxx undisputed
king of big wave surfing Laird Hamilton
the list goes on and on what do they
have in common they're sharing their
secrets their morning routines favorite
books everything with me on my podcast
the Tim Ferriss show 70 million plus
downloads iTunes best of 2015
check it out you will not be
disappointed